حياكم الله انتهى التصويت الذي اعلن عنه
الملياردير الامريكيه لو ماسك لتنحي على
رئاسه تويتر الاستطلاع حظيه بمشاركه اكثر
من 17 مليون شخص وصوت اكثر من 10 ملايين
شخص بنعم على تنحي ماسك بنسبه بلغت اكثر
من
57% في ما صوت
42% بلا وكان ماسك قد فاجا متابعيه
باستطلاع راي لاخذ اراؤهم حول تناحيه من
منصبه كرئيس لمنصه تويتر مؤكدا على ضروره
اخذ الحذر كما اكد على متابعيها انه
سالتزم بنتيجه استطلاع في اشاره الى
امكانيه تناحيه عن المنصب حال جاءت
النتيجه بذلك فهل سيتنحى ماسك على رئاسه
تويتر
[موسيقى]
معنى من دبي عبر زوما انس النجداوي
الاكاديمي والمستشار في اداره الاعمال
الرقميه والتقنيه ومن واشنطن عبر سكايبي
ايهاب عباس الباحث في الشؤون الامريكيه
اهلا بكمال يبدا اولا بسالكم هل سيتنحى
ماسك سيدنا
شلون المليون هذا
مساء الخير لكم مشاهدين الكرام بلا شك
طبعا من خلال مشهدهم من دراما يعني في
الفتره قصيره التي
وقع الامور تزداد سؤال اكثر من قبل فانا
اتوقع فعلا انه الامور سوف تتوجه او سوف
تنتهي بلا بتعيين رئيس جديد تويتر
اها طيب السيد
ايهاب عباس من يعني من واشنطن هل توافق
يعني انا اعتقد ان السؤال الى الماسك نفسه
عندما يقوم بطرح هذا السؤال عبر هذه
المنصه هو يجمع معلومات في البدايه هو
يريد ان يعرف حجم القبول او الرفض من قبل
المتابعين لسياساته واداته لهذه المنصه
الكبيره وبالتالي بناء عليها
كالرجل اعمال استثمر اكثر من 44 مليار
دولار في هذه المنصه ودخل في خلافات
ومشاكل كبيره مع الموظفين ومع قيادات
المنصه السابقه ومع كثير من المشاهير في
الولايات المتحده الخطوه القادمه الى
النصر ستكون همم يعني همم ان كانت بقصد
تنحي فهو سياتي بشخص يرتدي قناعا اخر ولكن
من ولكن من تحته الى الماسك هو الذي همم
يظهر بشكل الحقيقي ويدير هذه المنصه وانا
شخصيا ارغب ان يتنحى في الواقع لانه يمثل
تيارا مهما يجب ان يكون موجود داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في عهد تقدم
فيه اليسار همم التقدمي المتطرف كثيرا في
كل اشكال الحياه الامريكيه طيب سيد انس
يعني المدير الناجح اليوم هل في اداره
تسلا صاحب اكثر من من شركه الا ليكون
ناجحا لاداره هكذا مواقع الكترونيه او
منصات همم جديده في الاعلام الجديده
ليس بالضروره سيدي يعني بلا شك
هو
رئيس ناجح ملامح
وحقق الكثير من
النجاحات في طبعا من خلال افكاله الغير
التقليديه من خلال منصه من خلال شركه
وايضا الشركات الجديده التي تحاول ان يعني
تربط الذكاء صناعي وتطبيقاتها مع
انا انسان لكن لا يعني بالضروره سوف ينجح
ايضا في اداره منصه تويتر يعني هي من خلال
ما شفنا يعني من خلال الفتره الماضيه
الكثير من التخبط والكثير من الاخطاء
والقرارات التي زادت يعني الامر
وعن تراجعه في كثير منها من الاحيان هذا
يدل على انه لا يفكر بشكل
ايهاب ما اتحدث به ايضا ضيفه هنا من دبي
السيد انس النجداوي من انه قد لا يكون
مديرا ناجحا صاحب او راس صاحب راس مال جيد
له افكار عديده ولكنه بالفعل يعني
تتعلق بالمغردين امور يعلق حسابات صحفيين
لم تحدث من قبل ما الذي حدث لمصر
يعني ماسك على المستوى الاداره الاعمال
المتعلقه بالتكنولوجيا وشركه تسلا الى
اخره وسبيس اكس طبعا
لا يتصل مباشره
بالجماهير لكن عن طريق تويتر هذه منصه
يتبادل فيها الجميع الاراء والاراء
المختلفه من اكثرها تطرفا يمينا لاكثرها
التطرفا يا ساره وبالتالي ربما الى الماسك
يفتقد لهذه
المهاره مهاره التواصل بشكل يحقق له
الاستفاده الكامله والمطلوبه لكن هذا لا
يعني انه يجب عليه الاختفاء انا اعتقد ان
اختفاء ان الناسك من اداره همم منصه تويتر
سيشكل تحديات كبيره للمنصه ولكثير من
المستخدمين الرجل العاد وعادت مع حريه
التعبير لعشرات الالاف من الحسابات ربما
حسابات ثانيه يا سيدي انا متفق مع حضرتك
لكن لو حضرتك شاهد لماذا اتخذ هذه الخطوه
المؤقته مده اسبوع كانت بسبب ان هناك
مطارده لحساباته الشخصيه المتعلقه
بايلونجات على ما اعتقد والتي كانت تتبع
مسار طائراتي وحسابات اخرى تتبع مسار
ابنائه
كان هذا يبدو ان هؤلاء الصحفيين كانت لهم
علاقات بمجموعات التتبع يبدو انا غير
متاكد لكن خلينا اعود بهذا السؤال الى الى
ضيفه من هنا من دبي انس النجداوي يعني
سيدي هذا بيقول سيدير تويتر لهم ماسك وان
كان من خلف الستار كما يقال او حتى بقناه
عن اخر هو مدير جديد هل ستبقى السياسات
نفسها نفس قد لا تقبل ذلك
يعني يعني بدايه يعني بلا شكوى عنده يعني
قوه تاثيريه كبيره عبر المنصه قبل ان
يشتري ويستحوذ على المنصه ولا طبعا مما
زاد بثقته بنفسه وانه يستطيع ان يغير طبعا
الاسواق الماليه بتقليده واحنا راينا كيف
نكتب
وعنده تاثير كبير ولكن قال عندما تحول الى
مدير واصبح طبعا يكون بالقرارات بالاقالات
الجماعيه ويؤدي الى طبعا تكسير روح
المعنويه لدى الموظفين انا لا ارى انه هذه
الطريقه اداره صحيحه
خصوصا انه طبعا الشركه تمر الان في مرحله
تحتاج الى الابتكار تحتاج الى التطوير
وانت تخليت عن النصف همم
موظفين وهذا طبعا
والكثير من المضافين يعني
ايجابيه لهذا
ولا لا
ما تنطبق عليه
الدعايه السلبيه وقد تكون ايجابيه لتويتر
في بعض الاحيان ام ذلك لا ينطبق على ما
فعله ماسك يعني نرى نرى نتائج نرى نتائج
انسى انسحاب الكثير من المعلمين سحاب
الكثير من الشركه من هذه المنصه القلق
وعدم الثقه بمستقبل هذه المنصه هذه كلها
مؤشرات سلبيه يعني المفروض
الارباح ولكن الطريقه التي اتخذها
والاستراتيجيه التي تتبعها على ربما لم
تكن الافضل وغير موفقه للاسف همم وهذا
طبعا لان هناك كاسات اقتصاديه كبيره حتى
اصبحت تؤثر سلبيا على يعني على البراند
القومي
بالتنحي من رئاسه شركه طيب
ايهاب يعني سيد من التغريدات قرارات كثيره
ستدفع من ثمانيه دو لا لن تدفعها الى اخره
كل هذه القرارات هل هو ما يعني يتلمس
الطريق عن مرتبك في اداره هذا الموقع ام
ان المواقع الرقميه والاعمال الرقميه
بالتالي تختلف عن كل شيء مره به الى ماسكو
رغما انه كان مؤثرا في همم
كريبتو كرنسي مثلا العملات الرقميه
واعتقد انه سيظل مؤثرا ايضا في مجال
الديجيتال ميديا
وقدرات التواصل الاجتماعي سيكتسبها هذه
المهارات الى الماسك بكل تاكيد خلال
الفتره القادمه بسبب شخصيته الى الماسك
لديه شخصيه قياديه همم
[موسيقى]
جدا وتستطيع ان تتوافق مع اي شيء لكن يجب
ان نوضح نقطه لماذا قام الى الماسك بفصل
قيادات همم
تويتر ولما قام بفصل موظفينا كثر اولا في
الوقت الذي قام فيه باغلاق مكاتب وفصل
موظفينا كثر كانت ايضا شركه امازون تقوم
بنفس الشئ شركه وول مارت تقوم بنفس الشئ
تصريح الاف الموظفين هذه مشكله تتعلق
النواحي الاقتصاديه في المقام الاول ولكن
الى الماسك ايضا كانت لديه تصفيه حسابات
بسبب ان شركه ويرر عندما كان سينسحب من
شرائها اعلن ان الموظفين الكبار في الشركه
قاموا بتضليله وعدم اعطائه البيانات
الصحيحه والمطلوبه لذلك هو فضل الاستغناء
عنهم مباشره واعتقد اي شخص ياتي حتى في
المجالات السياسيه والشركات وفي ادارات
الادارات المختلفه دائما عندما ياتي شخص
جديد يحاول ان يهيء المكان لادارته
الجديده والا يكون هناك اي عقبات امامها
وبالتالي اعتقد هذه جاءت في هذا الاطار
الى الماسك لديه الكثير من
الشخصيات التي تستطيع ان تساعده في اداره
تويتر خلال الفتره القادمه ليستفيد
هو منها مادين واعتقد يعني بكل تاكيد الى
الماسك رجل اعمال لن يستغني عن واضح
اشكرك جدا ونحن ايضا نترقب ماذا سيكون
موقع تويتر ناجحا ام في مهب الريح باداره
الماسك او حتى من يراه مناسبه لهذه المهمه
شكرا يا سيدي ايهاب عباس البحث في الشؤون
الامريكيه من واشنطن وكذلك انس النجداوي
الى اكاديمي ومستشار في اداره الاعمال
الرقميه
والشكر لكم ايضا